um do you remember like I don't know the
first time the first concerts you ever
went to
what was yours I went to a Bon Jovi
concert with some friends it was really
young yeah yeah that's a cool first
concert it was it was amazing I I was a
little over excited I thought for I had
a button-up shirt over my t-shirt and I
don't I didn't know what to how to
behave at a concert so I just like threw
my button-up shirt on this day like yeah
yeah yeah right yeah you're right no
okay you threw your clothes on this day
well it's just my butt not all of them I
was like that's like a woman corresponds
at a rock show
oh yeah it's hard not to what about you
what was your first concert so I grew up
really Christian wasn't really allowed
to listen to secular I wasn't either
funny enough okay there we go yeah you
remember Carmen did I go to the concert
in Dallas Texas yes absolutely and it
was like a it was like a love offering
show you never had to buy a ticket you
just they've like passed a bucket around
like an offering plate yeah exactly so
Carmen would have been my first concert
oh my gosh that I don't know if that was
my first but it was one of my first and
it literally was where all the church
kids went like to go to a concert and
you felt like you were cool yeah it was
amazing he had people like dress up like
the devil
Jesus would fight the devil yeah crazy
storytelling it was like an adventure
yeah
Bon Jovi who
we were at Carmen I just love us like
reading about you know I was like oh my
God you weren't allowed to listen to
secular either yeah and now you're
making a secular record and like that's
my whole career our parents our parents
must be so disappointed
God invented love this is what we
discussed
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]